yes we have Fabiano Kanan here with us
Fabi welcome to the studio once again we
we didn't see you for a while how did it
go for you yesterday with a rapid
portion and today was Blitz yesterday
was quite good in Rapid I was quite
satisfied at the end of the rapid that
okay I still very much in the race to
day wasn't so good I have to say um a
bit too up and down and also not great
that Maxim had a had a really excellent
day and he's has a very very strong
position now not 100% let's say but very
strong position to win the tournament so
today I think I also did some very silly
things oh it's Blitz you know it's all
about Blitz I mean so in which shape you
have uh so did you feel at least good
today coming to the games yeah actually
I felt like I was playing quite well at
the start but I lost this game against
Sam that was very unfortunate because I
was just much better and I allowed a
sacrifice based on a blunder and uh if I
just don't allow him counterplay I'm
certainly much better and uh and can
definitely play for a win but you had
also some brilliancy brilliancy today
everybody was discussing it I mean y sir
Peter T everybody was screaming when
they saw this move Rook G6 you played it
so quickly can you show the game it was
against yeah no the thing is he kind of
got trapped in a line which I knew about
but I didn't remember any details I just
remembered that white delays castling so
that after black castles which is a
mistake then white again delays castling
and black can't break the pin uh because
the sacrifice is very strong so this was
all played in Anish against U ding Len
from
Bucharest and I think this is exactly
what happened but like you play Knight
F1 here you don't play Rook F1 I
mean this is how like Anish played of
course and then I remembered at some
point he played Rook F1 in that game and
I was like oh okay I'll play Rook F1
which is a ridiculous move of course um
uh so I just remember at some point in
the game he played Rook F1 and I decided
to do it now rather than Knight F1 which
is the first move that looked logical to
me then I yeah things went out of
control I mean certainly it looks
dangerous for black but but um I
blundered Knight f8 so I thought this
was strong I blundered Knight f8 then I
had no choice what to do I mean I'm down
two pieces so at least I saw I can
continue to sacrifice and still it's a
mess and he was down on time yeah okay
Rook h s I think like was it easy to
find this defense I mean you should
really see this Rook F6 coming probably
to understand that you have to play this
Rook h s and king8 but when you're
desperate then yeah I mean otherwise I I
lose so at least here I I continue
fighting yeah yeah Rook F6 King h8 okay
I mean he's down on time uh it's winning
but okay in Blitz I guess things could
happen here absolutely yes but yeah he
he didn't play Rook H7 here uh okay this
was also blunder but he was already down
to Second so when you're down to like 7
seconds in this position you play random
moves it's impossible to play yeah
considering the the time situation I
think maybe it was a a really good
chance that you found in this in this
game yeah no it was quite this was quite
important and also next game was quite
important for me that I beat Anish as
well yeah would you like to show it very
shortly I mean the moment probably just
a second of it I mean I don't know it
was kind of I got some position for
Italian which I thought like very
pleasant very pleasant for black I mean
this position for example yeah I should
have played D5 at this moment but it's
very pleasant position black can never
lose and okay I played D5 at the wrong
moment so looked kind of unclear but
still I my king is safer and my knight
on G5 is very good so the moment this
Knight came to F4 I thought you were
actually doing really well yeah
apparently this is the best moment in
the g no I think he blundered yeah I was
very surprised with Rook A3 I thought
actually like Rook A1 because he needs
to put this Rook on A3 to defend and
here I saw this B6 I was very happy at
this point it looks like white is
collapsing but of course uh
still maybe he didn't defend in the best
way and then also against Ray I should
have won that was kind of a Miss um yeah
I had very like winning very good
winning opportunity against Ray as well
but but yeah it's uh Blitz is always a
bit up and down absolutely and do we
have questions from y or just to be
sure no questions from me I've got a
question from Faby um yes wants to ask
you something every time we've got the
Royal lez against Fabby in the
commentary Studio we're waiting for him
to play his course to play archangels
and we haven't seen that in the
tournament so far what's the reason what
oh you you want him to what sorry what
what exactly you wanted him to play I
miss why is he ah why he not playing
what because I was out of what Tanya is
asking is uh Fab's done a chessable
course on theable course okay why don't
you play your variations what's wrong is
they're waiting why are you not playing
your open variations but now everyone
why don't you play your open everyone
can expect it so play some else no I
thought Maxim it's kind of funny to play
like the oldest possible variations I
played like like variations that people
have stopped checking in the last few
decades you know some ancient stuff
maybe it's a good trick like when was
the last time you saw choran in in a
high level game I mean it just doesn't
happen anymore so I it's actually not so
bad these these other variations yeah
other variations are not so bad guys now
we know yes that's it thank you for your
question and thank you Fabby and all the
best of luck for tomorrow I think it's
still not over everything is possible
yes hopefully thank let's hope thank you
to the studio uh thank you Fabby uh